et surtout on oublie pas et deux hippies
ça peut vous paraître étrange mais c'est
un truc que j'ai souvent entendu dans
les cours de mathématiques
vous savez quand on décompose un signal
en fréquence d'oscillation on a souvent
quelque part en maths et en physique
quelque chose qui traîne ses fameux deux
hippies qu'il ne faut pas oublier ou
faudrait-il les oublier ceux qui ont
suivi des cours avancés de mathématiques
ou de physique le savent le nombre pi ce
nombre le plus célèbre des mathématiques
ce nombre qui était le sujet de ma
première vidéo cents vols est souvent
accompagnée d'un facteur 2 c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous mais pour
moi ça veut dire beaucoup
ça veut dire que piller faut un fardeau
de l'histoire qu'on sera un bal ça
heureusement pihet fo
alors bien sûr pis n'est pas faux faux
ça reste le rapport de la circonférence
du cercle par son diamètre et ça reste à
peu près égale à trois points 14 en
particulier tous les théorèmes que l'on
a démontré sur pie reste vrai mais l
infra constante des mathématiques celle
qu'il faudrait envoyer à des aliens pour
leur montrer qu'on n'est pas
complètement débile
celles qu'il faudra utiliser dans les
cours de mathématiques ce n'est pas pis
mais le double de pi que certains ont
commencé à appeler tôt
tout commença en 2001 avec un article de
bob palais intitulé paillis brengues
mepi était un élément de culture si
incontournable que même les experts
n'étaient pas prêts à le sacrifier en
2010 michael orateurs décida de se
lancer dans le militantisme
mathématiques et publié le taux
manifesto qui encourageait ses partisans
à protester contre pis il invita les
touristes à donner de la voix notamment
le 28 juin ainsi baptisé le jour de taux
un an plus tard vaillard pris le relais
et le jour de pi exposa au grand public
les faits qui incrimine pi et j'ai été
conquis à tel point que deux ans plus
tard en 2014
j'ai parié un resto avec un ami que les
cours de mathématiques de 2034
utiliserait tôt et non pas piller et
ouais je suis un minuteur mathématiques
avec un énorme confie nantes et rennes
pour commencer parce que deux pays
apparaît tel quel dans ton de formule
utilisée taux plus tôt que pi
permettrait d'économiser beaucoup
d'encre banc peut-être pas tant que ça
mais avec un symbole de monde dans les
équations on diminue le risque de fautes
des tours 10 et surtout on gagne en
élégance
l'élégance mathématiques ça je peux vous
le garantir c'est sacré choisir taux
plus tôt que pin n'est pas juste une
question d'élégance mathématiques c'est
surtout une question de progrès
pédagogique
les mathématiciens préfère mesurer les
ongles en radiant plutôt qu'en de gris
un tour complet fait de pire radiant et
donc pire radiant fait un demi tour
du coup quand on mesure des angles comme
pays divisé par deux pays divisé par 3
ou pis divisé par 4 ou 10 de ses angles
qui sont des fractions un demi tour et
ça c'est troublant c'est pas naturel et
c'est pas facile à comprendre pourquoi
ton mesuré en demi tour pourquoi ne pas
simplement mesurer les angles comme des
fractions de tours complets ainsi un
angle droit correspond clairement un
quart de tour et ça en termes de taux
c'est tout bêtement dire qu'il s'agit
d'un angle de taux divisé par quatre
radiant un tiers de tours taux divisé
par 3 radiant
demi-tour tôt demi radiant facile non
même demanderiez vous pourquoi mesurer
les angles en radiant pourquoi ne pas
utiliser les degrés ou des trucs qui ne
font pas intervenir tôt opi bien la
réponse à cela est une histoire de
fonctions trigonométriques le sinus d'un
angle correspond à leur donner du point
du cercle unités repéré avec cet angle
ainsi on voit que le sinus d'un angle
nul est égal à zéro le sinus d'un quart
de tour lui est égal à 1 celui d'un demi
tour et 0 et celui de trois quart de
tour et moins un an par ailleurs à
l'aide d'un hexagone régulier inscrit on
voit que le sinus d'un douzième de tours
et 1/2
je vous laisse réfléchir et déterminé de
vous même le sinus d'un huitième de
tours est celui d'un sixième de tous
c'est bien joli tout ça mais ça
n'explique pas encore l'utilisation des
radiants considérons maintenant un tout
petit angle disons qu'il s'agisse d'un
millième de tours complets alors la
longueur de l'arc de cercle en gras est
un millième du périmètre du cercle or le
sinus de l'angle et la hauteur de cet
arc de cercle et cet arc de cercle et
quasiment intègre en vertical
du coup le sinus de l'angle est à peu
près égale à la longueur de l'arc de
cercle qui est égal à un millième du
périmètre du cercle or un cercle de
rayons un un périmètre égal à tôt donc
sinus d'un millième de tours est à peu
près égale un taux / 1000 et en
particulier les angles sont en radiant
alors le sinus de thau / 1000 va être à
peu près égale à taux / me plus
généralement on à l'approximation si
musique c'est à peu près égale à x pour
de petites valeurs de x ou pour utiliser
le langage de développement limité dont
j'ai déjà parlé dans cet épisode
l'approximation au premier ordre du
sinus d'un angle mesuré en radiant est
égal à l'ongle lui même et ça c'est
super joli mais surtout ça permet de
grandement simplifier les calculs
mais il ya mieux encore en utilisant les
radiant les mathématiciens ont découvert
une formule magique pour calculer le
sinus d'un angle de manière exacte
euler exploite à ces formules mystique
pour révéler l'une des plus belle
équation de toutes les mathématiques qui
consiste à décomposer ce que l'on
appelle l'exponentielle complexe en une
somme de sinus et caussinus selon la
légende lorsque l'air en place à la
variable par la constante pi et demi
tous du même côté
il obtint l'équation mystique le hippie
+1 est égal à zéro et euler s'écria
alors mais du coup du existe
métaphysique pseudo-scientifiques mise à
part je trouve cette équation vraiment
vraiment jolie elle met en jeu les
nombres 0 1 e i épis et les combine de
manière limpide avec une addition une
multiplication et une expo nantiat sion
mais il y a encore beaucoup plus jolie
pour moi l'équation la plus jolie qui
soit c'est celle que l'on obtient
lorsque l'on remplace à variable non pas
par pim et partent au n'obtient alors
l'équation e il taux est égal à 1 et le
message de cette équation est alors
beaucoup plus perspicaces que celle de
l'équation originale de l'air puisque ei
taux égal à 1 signifie que lorsque l'on
a parcouru une distance tôt le long du
cercle on revient au point de départ
autrement dit cette équation dit que
l'expo nantiat sion complexe de l'air
qui est une généralisation des fonctions
trigonométriques à une période égale à
taux et ça c'est vraiment le coeur du
message de la formule de l'air alors
bien sûr il y aura toujours des
nostalgiques conservateurs pour trouver
des raisons selon lesquelles avant
c'était mieux
ils ont par exemple dans ce cas nous
dire que dans l'équation originale de
l'air au moins il y avait le nombre 0 et
une addition sottise si vous aimez
vraiment le zéro et l'addition bien je
peux modifier l'équation e i taux est
égal à 1 pour ajouter une addition et 1
0 en écrivant le iie taux est égal à 1 +
bon c'est pas super joli mais bon vous
l'avez votre addition
bref je pense qu'il faut et je vous
invite à arrêter de traîner les bouley
du passé et à embrasser les
mathématiques dans toute leur élégance
et ça ça veut dire qu'il faut enterrer
pi est célébrée tôt les crèmes un
restaurant jeu
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
hors série qui est lié au livre du café
des sciences livre de café des sciences
est un livre de vulgarisation auquel de
nombreux vulgarisateur de la toile de
l'internet ont participé du coup je vous
invite vraiment aller acheter ce livre
mais aussi à aller voir les autres
vidéos qui sont associés à ce livre donc
en voici quelques-unes
c'est donc comme d'habitude vous invite
à commenter à liker et à partager cet
épisode et j'espère que je vous verrai
bientôt sur scène ce forum